School shooting in South Florida.
17 people shot to death.
What can be done about school shootings?
Some say, kids will be safer
if some teachers carry guns.
President Trump said that.
We need to let people know, you come in to our schools
you're gonna be dead.
Trump was mocked for suggesting teachers have guns.
Arm a teacher is completely insane.
It’s a terrible idea.
A terrible idea.
But Trump’s critics probably don’t even know
that many teachers have brought guns to school
for years.
In Texas, teachers carry in about 200 schools.
This high school advertises that.
I can see that sign out on the highway,
Boy it’s great, man.
Parents we interviewed here like the policy.
It’s a good idea.
I think we need it.
It makes me feel safer.
I love the Keene gun policy.
Superintendent Ricky Stephens created it, saying
if there’s trouble, teachers want
to go defend the kids.
We know our staff and our teachers are gonna go.
Do we want them to go with a pencil
or go with a pistol?
Everybody is against it.
This Florida student says teachers carrying guns
is a terrible idea.
You are asking a teacher to
fight an assault rifle with a hand gun.
That seems like a pretty
unfair fight to me.
The teachers have hand guns
against somebody with a big gun.
That's not much.
It's not much, but it's better than nothing.
If you go there with nothing,
you have no chance of stopping anything.
The police come, they see your teacher with a gun.
How do you keep them from shooting
her?
We train a lot with our local law enforcement,
so that helps us because we want them to at
least know we're there, and at least recognize us.
If they happen to get shot
while they're stopping a tragedy,
all of our guardians have said,
"That's just the price of being a guardian."
His teachers saw how during Florida school shooting,
the security guard waited outside.
It’s a reason she’s glad
she can carry her gun at school.
We hid her identity because she,
and the school,
don’t want a potential attacker
to know which teachers are armed.
Are you carrying now?
Many people say armed teachers created new dangers.
Teacher accidentally fired a gun in his classroom.
At this California school,
a teacher mistakenly shot at the ceiling.
One student was slightly hurt by falling debris.
But that’s the only incident we could find
where a student was injured.
On the other hand,
armed teachers have stopped school shootings.
16-year old Luke Woodham has been arrested.
When this student killed two classmates,
an assistant principal with a gun
held the killer at gunpoint until police arrived.
We don’t know how often
armed teachers deter shootings.
The media can’t cover crimes that never happened.
The media also distort what President Trump proposed.
Donald Trump said
teachers should have guns.
Teachers should not be required to protect and serve
and to teach.
Required?
No teacher is required to carry.
It’s voluntary.
Those who want to bring their guns to school can.
Here’s another distortion.
I really do not support the idea of arming teachers.
Arming Teachers.
Arming teachers?
A new federal program?
That’s not what the President proposed.
Lots of teachers already have guns.
All a school has to do is allow some to bring
their guns to school.
At the Keene School District, however,
Superintendent Stephens
did create a new government program.
The school purchases the gun,
and then we give them
and register them to our teachers.
That way, he says, he can make sure all teachers
have training on the same type of gun.
Finally, as we ponder the best way
to keep students safe,
we should address the scariest myth.
The epidemic of shootings…
Epidemic of school shootings…
Despite what the media say,
there is no epidemic of school shootings.
No sharp increase.
School shootings kill far fewer kids than
driving, suicide, drowning, even suffocating.
Why now?
School shootings are not in a big uptick.
Exactly right, but we prepare for them because
if even one shooting happens
it's more than
we would want.
You're 10 times as likely to die suffocating.
Right.
You can't protect against all these things.
No, but we do train our kids in school
how to not suffocate and how not to drown.
Certainly Stephens’ armed teacher program
is cheaper than what my town does.
New York City spends hundreds of millions of dollars
stationing police officers in and
around schools.
Of course here, and in most blue states,
suggesting that some teachers
carry weapons
horrifies people.
They don't understand
that a responsible trained teacher with a firearm
is better than having
a teacher with nothing.
Texas will definitely probably
be leading the way
when it comes to protecting our kids
with weapons,
and that New York would choose to go
a radically different way.
I’m glad that we live in a country
where the local people can decide
what goes on in their school district
and not a bunch of people in New York City.
It’s good that America has 50 states.
That allows experiments.
Teachers in New York City
may fear guns,
but teachers in Texas
can serve and protect.